it is hilarious and Gloria Stefan is in
it that she and I sing a song together
which is hilarious where we're insulting
each other that ends with this I'll kick
your ass there's Cubans in an overwrite
now we still have no plan changing
people's minds about politics is hard
how did you think it was going to go I
want to start kind of at the basics here
yeah they first come to you and they say
Rita here is your animated rendering of
Lydia what what was your reaction I
loved it they really got it oh they
wanted to I think they asked the
producers should we have her looking
older or should she look the way she
looks on the show and they said no the
way she cooks on the show but here's the
fun part
I read all my lines for the animators on
my cat on my iPhone because I wanted
them to see my expressions my
expressions are very strictly Lydia
expressions and not anybody else's so I
said if you don't mind here's how I
would say this this line and use the
expression that would appear on my face
they loved it and they did it and they
did it they hadn't been doing this a lot
you know well you know and I loved her
drinking the whiskey all the time I know
that getting into the Lydia character
probably really helps you feel like
Lydia and act like Lydia so even though
you're at home and you're recording you
know there's no camera did you still get
dressed did you do the whole Lydia look
you know I was in my pajamas
I'm an actress for pete's sake it comes
natural to you the drop of a hat I can
be like this and I don't know that I am
the God's gift to me you know I can get
into character in two seconds SMAP reina
del todo mundo is the queen of all the
world correct the experience of
recording at home what did you have to
do it was bizarre actually it was really
bizarre because all of the writers all
of them were on the other side and they
were also helping to react because when
you do comedy it's very different
do comedy when you're used to an
audience like we were of course the last
yes and it really makes a difference how
you time what you say and you know you
kind of have to guess and list instance
well this be a huge life will this be uh
just a guffaw will this be a smile and
let the writers did help but it was kind
of funny you know to hear the way loving
her own jokes they would read the other
person's line and then I would read only
mine so it's just my stuff isolated all
of the cast did the same thing they had
it was I selected which is kind of
difficult because the writer reading uh
no see those line is not at the same
it's not quite the same right especially
the two of you together it's just magic
oh we are we are great chemistry
especially when we disagree oh yes those
fights are what we live for I know we
live for those fights they're marvelous
do me a favor mommy you stay out of my
love life I made you a profile on tinder
says lonely Catholic nurse seeks big
strong man to fill the hole in her life
you might want to reward them Rita when
I sat with you on set in February yeah
you looked in the camera and you said
Lindman well get off your canítö we want
you here on one day at a time then man
will get off your kool-aid oh come on
man it's in animated form but you got
lin-manuel on one day at a time this is
that marvelous we have you to thank
did you pick up the phone how did this
all come about why do I always do that
of course of course I but also what's
important isn't that he's a big fan of
the show course a prevent so he really
honestly watches the show can you
imagine that I texted him when I saw it
the other night because I said I think
you stole the show he was every time you
did one of those things where he puts a
dent $20 billion into your Alex's face
because alex has said something that he
agrees with right Bob dude it was
hilarious
so you didn't get to record or really
work with him no no
I know I am know cuz I wasn't in the
machines with or if I wasn't the scenes
with him I didn't have anything to do
with him
right so uh it's not the best way in the
world to work that's right well you know
what it's a good it's a good step one
step two when the world resumes and you
can go back to work together I'm looking
at you Rita we got to get lemon well
back on the one day at a time actual set
absolutely absolutely and you know what
he's more than happy to do it but he's
probably the world's busiest quarter
rican world's busiest man he's got his
hand in so many different things oh my
gosh I know what a talent huh I'm not a
sweet sweet man with a huge conscience
and a heart as big as Detroit I mean you
guys were not messing around you got
Melissa Fumero you got Gloria Estefan
you've got lin-manuel Miranda what does
it mean to you to have these big names
come support one day at a time
well you know what uh I'm delighted
about it but I'm not surprised I would
think they would want to because it's
it's you know this is our this is our
treasure this is how we can talk to
America about who we are so that's very
important and it doesn't surprise me but
it should you likes me I think if we
come back on the air as human beings I
think I've always felt that under Garcia
should be a guest star because because
of Lydia is nuts for any of us yeah well
and I think it would be hilarious to see
you're you know just drooling all over
him
and I would look at corrosive room at
your father and I would go yeah this is
a very powerful episode of one day at a
time I want to know your reaction when
you saw the subject matter oh I was so
real beyond words
and I also I said to myself thank you
Lord for editing a independent TV on the
air it's not a please bad language but
you can't use that kind of political
language without you know having so many
repercussions and it's gotten a lot
better but I'm so thrilled to be doing
this kind
television I love it there are mentions
of so many things that are so poignant
that are happening right now if you turn
on the TV it's happening and the fact
that you guys were able to include it in
your script was this the original script
or were there revision the original
script with some rewrites but really the
rewrites even came then not right now
like what was the time frame maybe even
it was 11 weeks ago that that script was
written Wow that it hasn't changed that
much it's just it's changed only in
ferocity and an emotion I can't believe
we ever voted for that person what fools
we've been and boys to men is better
than instinct and I was always jealous
of your curly hair it could happen right
Oh mom no it's not going to go anything
like that what is it that you hope
viewers learn or take away from this
episode it's not fruitful yell at each
other and try to convince each other of
what is right and what it's not right I
think that's very very very important
the Alvarez's decide okay they are our
family we still love them we hate them
and we love them and that's wonderful
we're not different we speak different
languages we like different foods we're
still human beings right we have hearts
that beat we have blood streams we have
blood pressure and and we're not that
different of course I love seeing you in
animated form or but what's the good
bird on returning to work don't know yet
I know that there's talk about some of
it but I'll tell you given that I am 88
almost 89 I'm going to be very very very
very careful about going back to work
with people I hope that you are able to
safely get back to work cause you know
we're craving more we want more episodes
and I know you're gonna deliver them
that is my invention
you know I'll show you my in the back of
my
dress oh please I've been home now for
what three months gained a little weight
because I'm eating really well I'm
cooking my ass off you deserve it so
this is what happens though when you do
that you see this Rita it's sexy it's an
open-back dress oh the hell it is but
nevermind I don't care
I dress does not fit it's as simple as
that
that also means I'm not wearing a bra
haha Queen you live your best life
you're gorgeous you're timeless at any
age at any fly is truly I do want to ask
you because Emmy nominations are coming
out soon is it about damn time one day
at a time
got acknowledged yes I think it's
overdue as a matter of fact I think that
Justina Machado is one of the best
actresses on television I really do uh
when we did our very first script
reading initially the very first one at
a table I said my god this girl is
amazing she's a voice and she can bring
tears to your eyes like this she does
these astonishing switches yeah I still
don't understand why
Justina hasn't got one of those big time
committees Rita it's not every day that
each he gets invited into your home I am
curious where do we keep the pig got all
of them all of them are on shelves and
in the living room every once in a while
just so people understand this I will be
in the living room I'm walking by or
doing something or putting flowers on
this lovely little white piano we have
and I said me I just stop and look at
the applause and I think who would have
thunk Wow
a little Puerto Rican girl Wow it's nice
I do stop I'm not I'm not casual about
it at all you forget I'm in a bed
1962 you won your Oscar so we're coming
up soon on the 60 year anniversary of
you being the the pioneer the first
Latina woman to win an Oscar what do you
remember about that pivotal moment it
was it was the most extraordinary moment
of my life
you see Oscar thank you yeah and here's
what sits next to it that's a soccer
trophy from your grandson yes that's the
older one it was one of those moments
that I've it took me months to really
digest it I couldn't believe that this
little Puerto Rican girl just came in a
rush to me and Here I am in West Side
Story again is that crazy is that crazy
with Steven Spielberg yeah full circle
do you ever catch yourself still singing
the songs around the house where's
Andrew I was singing one this morning I
feel pretty I feel pretty I feel pretty
and witty and gay and I pity any girl
who isn't me today
[Music]